[Musique]
ce matin là la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale a pris place dans un train
direction Dijon à 300 km du palais
Bourbon
moi je considère que lorsqu'on fait de
la politique on l'a fait avant tout pour
les gens et avec les gens et donc aller
à la rencontre des Français quel que
soit le moment quelle que soit les
circonstances pour moi c'est vraiment un
impératif être voilà apporter à
proximité
c'est c'est pour ça qu'on fait de la
politique autrement il faut faire autre
chose il ne faut pas avoir peur de la
confrontation il ne faut pas avoir peur
du débat il ne faut pas avoir peur de la
critique parfois et donc c'est je crois
mon 20e ou 21e déplacement depuis que je
suis élu
alors à Fontaine française Yaël Braun
Pivet vient inaugurer un nouveau réseau
de chaleur pour ce village de 800
habitants
avec beaucoup de plaisir
bravo
et comme à chaque déplacement elle en
profite pour savoir ce que l'on pense de
son institution
[Musique]
est très raisonnable
heureusement parfois c'est le bazar mais
la plupart du temps ça n'est pas mais
malheureusement on n'arrive pas à le
voir ça puis il y a le passage obligé
devant la presse locale la présidente de
l'Assemblée c'est qu'elle est au centre
de l'attention dans les prochains jours
elle doit rendre une décision sur la
proposition de loi liotte qui veut
abroger la réforme des retraites une
décision qui pourrait être très
contestée alors on est parti
[Musique]
bonjour à tous La séance est ouverte
sur la semaine à venir comment vous vous
l'aborder un petit peu notamment jeudi
moi ma boussole c'est l'institution que
j'ai l'honneur de présider et
l'application de nos règles communes
l'Assemblée nationale c'est le lieu du
débat organisé et je m'efforce au
quotidien de m'assurer que ce débat
organisé puisse avoir lieu selon les
règles qui ont été définies par d'autres
que nous avant nous et qui nous
subsisterons après nous je vous remercie
en Côte d'Or comme ailleurs la
contestation contre la réforme des
retraites et toujours vives pour la
deuxième étape de son déplacement il y a
El Braun Pivet a le droit à un comité
d'accueil des militants de la CGT et
leur casseroles
les députés qui l'accompagnent hésitent
un peu mais païel Brown PIB
[Musique]
bonjour
monsieur bonjour madame bonjour
vous voulez bien me serrer la main moi
également bonjour madame bonjour madame
monsieur bonjour monsieur
mais heureusement parce que les règles
on est tous
c'est
avec vous
exactement
depuis le début de la procédure du vote
à l'Assemblée nationale vous fuyez vous
fuyez
la macronie la démocratie
l'ensemble des organismes syndicales
sont contre l'ensemble la majorité des
parlementaires sont en cours parce que
vous avez peur d'aller au vote donc
laissez aller jusqu'au maths laissez
aller jusqu'au 20 c'est ça le problème
la réforme des retraites
un vote final lorsqu'elle a été discutée
à l'Assemblée nationale pourquoi parce
que mais non parce qu'on a eu 20 000
amendements qui ont fait nous n'avons
pas pu débattre de tout le temps
mais tout le monde le voit c'est gros
comme le nid au milieu du visage pour
parler de discuter mais en fait vous ne
m'écoutez pas vous ne nous écoutez pas
le pays depuis le mois de janvier vous
dit qu'il veut pas de cette réforme et
vous ne nous écoutez pas à chaque fois
que je fais un déplacement et qu'il y a
des délégations de personnes qui veulent
me parler je vais leur parler
en garde une grosse fracture avec la
population que le peuple français des
travailleurs les retraités et le même la
jeunesse vous rendez pas compte ce que
vous êtes en train de faire c'est très
grave
[Musique]
un dialogue difficile
après
c'est ça permet au moins de
[Musique]
mes en dialogue nécessaire pour la
Présidence de l'Assemblée
[Musique]
qu'on a eu des échanges on n'est pas
d'accord évidemment il faut les entendre
il faut entendre la colère parce
qu'autrement ça sert à rien si c'est
juste leur parler pour leur dire j'ai
raison et vous avez tort il faut
entendre
la faire faut toujours expliquer
pourquoi on a agi là on n'a pas pu
rentrer dans le fond des choses mais il
ne faut en tout cas jamais renoncer à
aller à la rencontre à dialoguer et à
essayer de se comprendre mutuellement
même si on ne convient pas forcément à
la même si on ne convient pas forcément
à la fin c'est effectivement notre lot
mais en tout cas ne jamais renoncer
merci à vous
changement de décor le Tour de France de
la présidente de l'Assemblée s'arrête
dans les Yvelines il y a elle brune
pivée vient parler démocratie bonjour à
tous déjà je voudrais vous remercier de
vous être rendu disponible pour ce temps
d'échange on peut parler du mode
d'élection du président de la République
des députés de la durée du mandat est-ce
que il faut revenir à 7 ans est-ce qu'on
reste à 5 ans voilà moi je tous les
sujets sont ouverts donc voilà à vous
monsieur je pense que le 49.3 c'est à
peu près l'équivalent de Lady royal de
de il y a 300 ans et ça c'est
inadmissible ne vous étonnez pas que les
gens n'aillent plus voter qu'il n'est
plus confiance parce que nos politiques
ont pris l'habitude de nous trahir pour
moi la base de supprimer le 49-3 parce
que à part montrer à la population que
peu importe si elle se base si elle sort
dans les rues si elle montre son
mécontentement et ben ce que le
président a décidé c'est ce qui se fera
donc pour moi c'est la base c'est de
supprimer le 49
au procès du 49.3 elle tente la
pédagogie moi je fais pas le lien entre
la confiance et le 49-3 mais peut-être
que c'est une erreur de ma part pour
qu'on dit 49,3 c'est un article de la
Constitution c'est un outil il a été
conçu pour permettre au gouvernement de
pouvoir continuer à mettre en oeuvre une
politique et de ne pas avoir un blocage
complet du pays cet outil pendant le
Parlement peut mettre en jeu la
responsabilité du gouvernement en votant
une motion de censure le gouvernement
lorsqu'il enclenche le 49-3
il joue sa vie puis chacun y va de sa
proposition
allez-y monsieur
pourquoi
le premier ministre également donc c'est
jamais compris pourquoi le vote
électronique n'a pas été mise en place
pour que les gens ils voter il faut
qu'ils se sentent représentés une fois
la fin de l'élection et pour cela il
faut absolument qu'il y ait une dose de
proportionnelle sur la proportionnelle
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez dans
la proportionnelle est quelque chose
dont on parle beaucoup comme vous la
présidente reprend alors ses réflexes de
l'hémicycle
qui serait pour ça en parler de doses
pas dose nationale départementale mais
juste sur le principe la proportionnelle
qui est pour
peu importe
qui est contre
vous êtes un certain nombre vous êtes
abstenus
il y a chez ses habitants des Mureaux
une inquiétude cette discussion
va-t-elle servir à quelque chose
j'ai une petite remarque c'est pas
forcément une question au bureau on a
souvent des visites et des politiques et
en fait je me rends compte qu'il y a
plein de gens qui viennent nous voir
mais après il y a le lien est rompu on
sait plus ce qui s'est passé on sait pas
si ce qu'on a dit ça a eu un impact on
sait pas si ce qu'on a pensé ce qu'on a
transmis a été vraiment partagé et que
ça a eu du sens
à quoi ça sert je pense que ça c'est une
des questions et la jeune fille ouais
elle a changé elle est là-bas ça fait
plusieurs fois qu'on voit des gens venir
aux Mureaux et on sait pas à quoi ça
sert on n'a pas rédigé ce soir une
nouvelle constitution c'était pas
l'objectif en revanche on s'est dit des
choses ça ne veut pas dire que les
citoyens sont décisionnaires de tout le
temps mais les aliments que nous
réflexion donc c'est à ça que ça sert
pour réformer les institutions la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
consulte les groupes politiques mais
elle veut surtout entendre les citoyens
c'est effectivement
indispensable d'associer les citoyens à
cette réflexion puisque vous savez
lorsque vous faites de la politique vous
la faites avant tout pour les gens et
donc réformer notre vie démocratique
sans les Français on aurait juste aucun
sens et donc avoir ce dialogue constant
lorsque je mène ces consultations
politiques à l'Assemblée nationale
l'avoir avoir ce dialogue avec les
Français me semble incontournable
redorer l'image de l'Assemblée
rétablir la confiance entre les Français
et le monde politique il y a El Brown
Pivet le sait il faudra du temps pour y
parvenir
[Musique]